everyone talks about writing authentic
characters we all want that and we all
want to watch that but how do you know
you're writing an authentic character
and how easy is it I think that
especially if if you are I mean if
you're writing about anyone who wasn't
you I think it's very important to do
research and why I mean my research is
kind of like you know I mean I I kind of
employed a neo-realist strategy in in
lolly and then I go where I I asked
teenagers from the community that I was
portraying and I think that that's what
you know that's what you need if you
want to try and make a character more
authentic is you really have to like you
know sit down and interact and spend
time and like listen to to the kids in
order to like you know capture their
their unique voices when you had done
the two-minute film of which was your
first project at UCLA did you already
have the idea for your feature film no
not yet you hadn't okay you know so then
you went back a second time and you did
the short film where it was wasn't a
spelling bee but it was an audition
so that was the the first so the first
short okay where's the audition was 88
and then this the second short film that
I shown in Compton with and also had mr.
Huang Moreno so in it and that was cool
the hood and that was short in 2016 the
lolly and then it was only shot in 2018
okay what point though did you say you
know what I feel I want to tell more
stories from this community how do i how
do I get this feature going and how do I
come back and pose this question you had
used the schools right or as well right
yeah we did yeah we were lucky enough to
get to shoot at Compton high school but
even that wasn't that easy that I mean
my producers can attest the fact that
that was quite a process getting
permission to shoot there but I think
you know I couldn't have
without the help and support of mr.
Reynoso so he was definitely you know
instrumental that when I communicated to
him like you know I mean I I enjoyed you
know shooting in Compton so much and you
know I really really loved the the
people and the stories and the urban
environment I mean he was the one who
kind of said yep sure anytime you want
to you want to come to class I'll
introduce you to my kids who who are
interested in in acting and you can just
take it from there so then did you go
back and write a script and have certain
people that you'd already met in mind I
did already have some some people
already in mind but I think that when I
started the casting process I think I
had a first draft and I started the
casting process in January of 2018 and
did you ever envision that this film
will go to Sundance oh definitely not
no not at all so it wasn't like you said
hey guys we're gonna shoot this film and
our goal is to go there and you and you
sort of prepped them I mean you can
always you can always say like oh you
know this film is gonna go here here and
there but you don't know I don't think
anybody really knows Wow unless you're
like super mega successful and you
already know exactly what you what
you're doing with your life but none of
us did well how do you write a great
scene I personally think that you you
write a first version which is what you
was a writer think you know this is what
this seam needs to do this is the
function that this scene has in in the
film I mean just just as a basic scene
goal you know advancing the plot of the
thing of the of the film or like you
know establishing an important dynamic
or an important connection and then I
personally what I like to do is then
workshop it with the actors and have you
know give them the opportunity to kind
of like okay you know the first time we
run it let's let's stick to the to the
script and then the second time we run
it feel free to improvise you know feel
free to you
live-live your character and live your
character in the specific moment in this
specific space with Europe with your
scene partner and then and then from
that you can get these really you know
precious moments these like gems that
then what I then do is write them back
into the shooting script
you